à cette période de l'année la jetée
d'arcachon est habituellement bondées
cette année le front de mer n'a pas le
même visage les hôtels restaurants et
casinos sont encore fermées malgré
l'autorisation de réouverture pour
certains commerces avec 12000 habitants
à l'année et près de 200 milles au plus
fort de l'été la saison estivale sera
exceptionnelle et atypique dans le sens
négatif selon le directeur général du
tourisme en nouvelle aquitaine en
l'absence de touristes l'économie locale
se fragilise considérablement
on n'ouvre pas ce qu on a l'autorisation
d'ouvrir mais en fin de compte on n'a
pas la clientèle touristique qui va avec
un type d'établissement comme le mien
donc je m'occupe je nettoie mais pour
l'instant c'est comme si si j'ai été
fermés donc ça ne sonne change rien pour
l'instant pour une station balnéaire
comme la nôtre si les restaurants les
hôtels ouvrait sa as ça changerait tout
c'est certain que le gros de la saison
commence à partir du mois d'avril les
vacances de pâques la cette époque si on
a du monde partout il fait beau la
normalement la jeter plein la promenade
est pleine mais là vraiment nous sommes
très très mal tous en plus on a dû
effectuer beaucoup d'investissement pour
faire les les paravents les touski
équipements pour se protéger de
on avait eu beaucoup d'investissement ou
de l'argent qui ne rentre pas l'état a
annoncé un plan de 18 milliards d'euros
dettes destinés à l'industrie du
tourisme oat hôtels et au restaurant une
aide déguisée pour les restaurateurs
puisqu'il s'agit d'un simple report de
charges
on a un report des charges le pré que
nous accordent des banques c'est suivant
dossier bon nous ça va mais on a
beaucoup de collègues qui n'ont pas pu
avoir ces prélats après bon à décharge
des aides de l'état concernant le
chômage partiel mais nous étant
restaurateurs on a droit à vraiment à
rien parce que le report des charges
pour nous on écrira plus tard
donc ce n'est pas vraiment de l'aide
donc on va on a tous peur parce que on
va beaucoup moins travaillé cet été et
voilà on a quand même beaucoup de choses
à payer à la fin lueur d'espoir enfin la
réouverture de certaines plages ce
week-end sous l'égide du concept de
plage dynamique et en respectant les
horaires qui devrait être compris entre
9 heures et 19 heures une réouverture
qui devrait ramener un peu plus de
clients aux commerçants des stations
balnéaires du littoral français